you  never meet your heroes well I did  and it was awesome  the Avengers were everything I imagined  hello San Francisco Thor Tony check it  out  at once try to keep up  this just got a whole lot more  interesting let's make this quick  secure the bridge those one  I can't get into the city are you  sitting up Bob nothing down  door what's your status there are humans  trapped lots of small Angry Men with  Scottie is that a joke  the door make a joke  [Music]  Tony thorn the cables chap what's going  on over there  start to chimera what's your status  should head back no stay on task  there's  [Music]  some say they were set up others call  them murderers do the Avengers pose a  danger to society that was the question  Bruce that was the question  well we all lost something that day but  that's not how this story ends  [Music]  well what are we waiting for  [Music]  you